ورقه بورقه تنهمس يوران في ترميم صفحات
مخطوطه تاريخيه تعود الى القرن السابع عشر
هي عمليه دقيقه تبدا من هوامش الورقه
ويمنع خلال استخدام قفازات اذ تحتاج الى
تحسس النتوءات والفراغات باماملها اما
الادوات الاخرى فتقتصر على فرشاه ومرقه
وقطع ورق مطابقه للمخطوطه فالسر يكمن في
ادخال الحد الادنى من التغييرات والاضافات
على المخطوطات خلال عمليه الترميم
بعد تفكيك اوراق الكتاب القديم نرمم
الصفحات المتاكله ولا نستخدم سوى الماء في
عمليه اللصق بعدها ننتقل الى مرحله الضغط
والتجفيف
تفضل يوران اتباع الطرائق التقليديه
المتمثله في وضع قطعه رخام لتضغط بثقلها
على الورقه المعالجه وتستغرق هذه المرحله
اسبوعا على الاقل حتى تصبح الورقه مسطحه
تماما
تليها مرحله تجميع كل الصفحات وضغطها من
جديد قبل خياطتها وتغليف الكتاب وخلال
المرحله النهائيه تضاف قطع حرير الى زوايا
المخطوطات للحفاظ عليها من التلف لاطول
وقت ممكن
تفيد الارقام الرسميه ان نحو 30 مليون
مخطوطه تاريخيه تحتاج الى ترميم غير ان
اعداد المرممين المتخصصين لا تتجاوز الالف
في جميع انحاء الصين 21 منهم معتمدون لدى
المكتبه الوطنيه وهو عدد ضئيل تسعى اداره
المكتبه الى زيادته عبر دورات تدريبيه
لتاهيل دفعات جديده
المعلم تشو هو احد المدربين القلائل
المتخصصين في ترميم المخطوطات التاريخيه
فعند انضمامه الى هذا القسم بالمكتبه
الوطنيه في ثمانينيات القرن الماضي كان
عدد المرممين لا يتجاوزوا اصابع اليد
الواحده ويعمل اليوم على تلقين المهارات
التي اكتسبها لعدد قليل من الشباب
الراغبين في ذلك
منذ عام 2007 عملنا جاهدين على تخريج
دفعات جديده من المرممين وقد تضاعفت
اعدادهم نحو 10 مرات من مئه الى الف متخصص
في جميع انحاء الصين لكن العدد ما زال
قليلا
ما زالت المكتبه الوطنيه في بيجين تسعى
الى استقطاب اكبر عدد ممكن من الشباب
لامتهان حرفه ترميم المخطوطات فهي من
الحرف المهدده بالزوال لصعوبه اتقانها اذ
تحتاج الى جمله من المهارات كاتقان اللغه
الصينيه الكلاسيكيه والشعر القديم
والتاريخ ما يجعل الاقبال على تعلمها
ضعيفا شيماء الجزيره بيجيم